who's gonna be the people's princess kev
that's the question that everyone is
asking because kate is now emerging from
megan's shadow
but a new report out suggests that kate
is tackling
too much what's really upset
kate in all of this is the suggestion
that she feels exhausted and trapped in
her royal role
it's rare to see kensington palace go
into firefighting mode and
issue a statement denying an article but
it's not
unknown for them to take legal action
et has confirmed the royals lawyers sent
a letter asking tattler to pull their
story
some of the publication's claims kate is
furious
she's working as hard as a top ceo has
to be
wheeled out all the time and has become
perilously thin
just like some point out princess diana
there's no question that william and
kate have had to do more since harry and
megan ditched their royal duties
but we're told there's actually a
strategic reason behind william and
kate's new image
cambridge has hired the sussex's media
coordinator when the sussex is quick
royal life
so i don't think it's any coincidence
that we're seeing a slightly
slicker operation online from seeing
them do zoom
conference calls from the comfort of
their home office
to allowing us to see rare footage of
their children
yeah homeschooling is fun
don't tell the children we've actually
kept it going through the holidays i
feel very mean
certainly with kate she has made herself
far more relatable than ever before
he's so sweet and one thing's for
certain
kate's glad that megan has left the
monarchy there was a sense of relief
i think for for kate particularly there
was
certainly tension behind the scenes
there were fallouts there were tears
but life in la has become increasingly
problematic for harry and megan
e.t has learned the couple is spending
more than eight thousand dollars a day
using the security team that protects
tom hanks j-law streisand and cher
a source tells us megan has received
racist threats before
they feel like they're being invaded
it's especially scary when they're
outside
with archie they accept that they are
going to be photographed out and about
doing their thing
but the idea of drones going over their
properties trying to take photographs of
them
playing with archie in the garden i
imagine there will be legal complaints
and legal action
to come further down the line